[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to the data
science hangout
if you're joining for the first time i'm
rachel and it's great to meet you
so if this is your first hangout what is
it well this is an open space for the
whole data science community to connect
and chat about data science leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science
so these sessions are recorded and
shared to youtube as well as the data
science hangout site so you can always
go back and re-watch or find helpful
resources too
i'll say this up front as well we do
have a linkedin group
too that people can join and i'll have
tyler share oh she just shared it right
there in the chat right now if you ever
want to continue a certain discussion or
connect with people that can be helpful
too
we always want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's three ways you can ask
questions today
as you may know this is all audience-led
so you can jump in by raising your hand
on zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and just put a little star if you wanted
me to read it out loud instead
or i could call on you
and then tyler will also share a link to
our slido where you could ask questions
anonymously as well
just like to reiterate we love to hear
from everybody no matter your industry
or level of experience as well
but today i'm so happy to be joined by
my co-host
david meza
your title is a mouthful here so aiml r
d lead of people analytics at nasa
and david i'd love to can i turn it over
to you to share a little bit about your
role and the work that you do
great thank you rachel appreciate the
the introduction so hi everybody uh i'm
glad to be here
taking this hour with you guys so my
role currently at nasa so i joined the
office of the chief human capital
officer at nasa headquarters about four
years ago my career at nasa is a little
over 20 years most of it down at the
johnson space center as the chief
knowledge architect
but what i'm doing currently right now
is very similar to what i did at jsc
on the knowledge architecture but it's
basically taking a look at our our
infrastructure in how we take data
from its authoritative source and turn
it into some kind of actionable
knowledge uh so so i look at that from a
framework of what i call again what i
call knowledge architecture which is a
combination of knowledge management
informatics and data science
where we look at knowledge management as
the
strategy for how we collect we analyze
we store we we present and visualize our
data informatics is the pipeline
for trans transforming or transmitting
that data from the authoritative source
to the presentation layer and then data
science are the methods and algorithms
we use to turn that data into some kind
of actionable thing so in people
analytics
i'm applying those concepts in within
human capital to see how we can
make a very cohesive
pro workflow between all of our four
architectures and undefined the
architectures is the data architecture
the it architecture the software are the
analytics architecture and the software
architecture to make sure that we can
get the data we can integrate it through
the it we could analyze it and
eventually present it to our individuals
we've got a long way to go within people
analytics to try to
modernize our stack
to see how we can do things
so it's kind of my job to make sure that
all parties are talking to each other
we're thinking about things we're
including the right tools such as our
studio
which you know and different types of
things that we're trying to utilize and
help our data scientists to answer the
questions that our end users are having
so that's kind of a brief rundown of
what i'm doing right now
that's great thanks david and if anyone
can hear they're doing a sound check for
a concert right next to the
office so apologies
um but david i'd love to ask you what's
something you're most excited about in
the next year ahead with regards to data
science
something i'm most excited with regards
to data science
i i think it's well
one of the reasons i came into this into
people analytics is because i really
felt that data science was becoming was
really starting to become mainstream
within people analytics so i'm really
excited about the aspect of how we're
utilizing various concepts and
technologies a lot of my focus
is around natural language processing as
well as graph algorithms and graph
databases
so it's the combination of actually
being able to utilize the graph
databases and graph algorithms
programmatically
in connecting to our data and creating
those pipelines finding information
within our text
creating that knowledge graph and then
being able to apply various algorithms
to it to deliver answers in just a
simple example of what we're doing there
is around our skill
and competency capabilities as you know
we're trying to get back to the moon and
on to mars
but we need to identify the various
skills and competencies that we have in
our individual
and and just
on from a human perspective that's very
labor-intensive so we're trying to use
some of our
some of these concepts that i've just
mentioned to be able to extract
nasa-specific competencies
from individuals
or or people that may be applying for
jobs based on some textual reading and
then creating a graph of those comp of
those competencies to see how they align
to our workforce and they're starting to
develop pipelines and methods to say
we've got gaps here or here's your
here's your career path here's your
trading path here are the number of
individuals that we have that meet 70 70
percent of our skills and we need to up
skill into the next 30 percent and we've
identified that through various
algorithms
i mean i'd say
that's a lot of words for for just
basically saying you know we're just
trying to
make sure that our staff is
appropriately aligned to get to the moon
and bond to mars
and i would love to hear what are some
of the nasa specific competencies
well i mean when you look at it i mean a
lot of them are are pretty close or
pretty aligned with with engineering of
course electrical engineer mechanical
engineering um different types of
research
but when we're talking about getting
onto the moon you know there's there's
propulsion capabilities aerospace type
capabilities that very few people have
done um and things that we've done that
we've unfortunately forgotten about you
know there's we've had to go back to our
apollo era days and look at uh you know
how we how we use the uh the parachutes
to land uh uh the rocket the capsule
back in into the ocean uh we forgot how
to do that so we had to go back and test
that out again and redo it it's because
of our knowledge management capabilities
we
while the information was stored we
didn't keep it in a way that it was
easily accessible
so we've learned from that but
definitely propulsion is it's a big
issue
robotics in how we utilize robots right
now on mars with uh with robonaut and on
on the
marshall lander
things like that that
take some
specific skills and understanding of how
to get those mechanisms onto a
another planet or onto the moon
that's awesome
um so there are a few questions coming
in on slido right now and one of the
first ones was david nasa is like a
dream company for lots of people and
kids how did you get there
how did i get here
you're testing my memory here
well
actually it was uh uh
luck maybe but fortunately i grew up in
houston uh and i grew up in the area
where johnson space center was so i knew
a lot of individuals that had worked for
nasa or were through there i was
actually in industry i was running a
small company
and
really decided to get back into
computers i mean this is a this is the
day and age where computers were just
starting you know i started off as an
engineer went into computer science
primarily because
the computer science majors were doing
their coding on a monochrome monitor you
know system of an 8088 computer rather
than punch cards because i didn't want
to do punch cards
within the engineering department
so it was just knowing people at that
time and applying for a job as
it was really booming that needed it
help i was able to get land an i.t
position with a contractor
of nasa uh down at johnson space center
and after about six years as a
contractor i was able to then apply for
a civil servant position which i was
hired on upon for that
so it's really just keeping an eye out
for the opportunities that are there
um keeping your your resume up to date
and and then it definitely does help if
you have some some somebody that can
provide a reference or understanding of
how nasa works
it is a little competitive
my last
announcement that went out i probably
had close to
three or four thousand applications
when it came in so so it uh
it can be competitive but but it's not
undoable
4 000 wow
so this might be
this question is a tied to that then
someone asked how baked into recruiting
and performance management are the
analytics you're working on
is this more aspiration or practical
currently
um
can i say semi-practical
in a sense we've got some good
performance and capabilities we've got
some good uh recruiting capabilities
that are out there
that are probably
a little more old-school uh utilizing
older technologies or utilizing some
manpower
the the
the analytic components of it are more
aspirational right now i mean we do have
some decent nutrition models we do have
some time to hire models that we're
utilizing that that are in in the in
production
but a lot of the other things we're
looking at are still somewhat
aspirational but we're moving a lot
closer kind of why they brought me in a
couple of years ago was to get to that
point where it's more production ready
you know think about what we need to do
implement the architecture work with the
agency to implement the architecture so
that we can do those things analytically
that we're trying to do
so it's a work in progress but like
anything in the government unfortunately
we run a little slow
so it takes some time to get these
things developed
thank you
somebody else had to ask on slido how
large is the people analytics team at
nasa can you tell us a little bit about
how the team's organized
sure
so the people analytics team right now
we've got about 10 civil servants and
another
five or six contractors so so with the
way you know with the government agency
if you're not familiar with you know
you've got you've got a combination
generally a civil servant and
contractors that do the work and within
nasa we have right out right around 18
000 civil servants but we have another
50 to 60 000 contractors in any given
time working on various projects so
within the people analytics team again
there's about 10 or 10 or so civil
servants in the five or six contractors
but then we have tangential
people on the team that may work for
other organizations across other
human resource organizations
across nasa at the various centers that
i can pull upon so they may be doing
an hrbp role an hr business partner role
but part of their work is also to do
analysis i can pull on them to do some
analytics at the various centers
so we have if you add those folks in
maybe another 20
but the core team is really the 10 civil
servants
great thank you
and just a reminder if people want to
raise their hand and ask questions live
feel free to do that too or you can use
the zoom chat i know a bunch of us are
using slido as well
um
libby i see you just put a question into
the zoom chat do you want to jump in
sure i might be misunderstanding people
analytics because it's not my field i
was wondering if you include things in
your research um or any of your modeling
or anything that are external to nasa
that are like stem graduation rates
things that like down the line might
inform nasa's ability to hire people
people that will be available to be
hired
definitely i mean i take a good part in
that in looking at external research and
seeing what we can utilize but some of
the things we've got uh contracts with
gartner uh with their their talent
neuron if you're familiar with that it's
basically a platform of looking at
hiring in job
opportunities across the not across the
world actually but you can focus on
different areas
there are other tools such as
burning glass or glass door
the census bureau of course provides us
a lot of information uh and then we have
our our internal nasa external data
sources uh usa jobs which is where we uh
post all of our announcements and jobs
we can see you know what's being
asked for across the government or usa
staffing which is the actual
location where all the resumes and
everything come in and we get you know
all the information about the candidates
and and
we can look at that
but
looking at those trendings
like you were talking about
a lot of that comes from external
data sources again like gartner burning
glass glass door some some of those
places that we can look at but i'm also
trying to
look at other
ipads i guess from
which is the education i don't remember
what the actual acronym stands for but
there's a lot of educational type data
in there looking at colleges and
universities the graduation rates uh
things like that the demographics break
out so i'm trying to incorporate a lot
of those various data sources to help us
inform
where we're pulling from and one of our
and it's going to become bigger because
one of our big focuses this year in onto
the next several years is the
administration's
requirement or executive order on deia
or diversity equity inclusion and
accessibility in how we look at that and
a lot of that revolves around
recruitment and internships
and are we using the
minority service serving institutions
and things like that so we are
definitely trying to expand our external
data sources
that's awesome thank you i come from a
minority surveying institution i
appreciate that yes i do
thanks david
um i'm
thinking as well for for people not as
familiar with people analytics or maybe
teams that are
thinking about getting started with
people analytics what are
all the kind of different areas that you
focus on
that's a good question
um so people on the list can definitely
be broken into into so many different
areas so uh you can look at you know of
course there's some of the basic ones of
course are your attrition your time to
hire your recruitment capabilities
um
there's a lot of different modeling or
research you can done let me where did i
put my book
uh somewhere there there's a good book i
want to i could share with you guys on
people analytics uh and some of the
different types of metrics but
um
really any any particular data scientist
that just has common knowledge on on
those capabilities so nlp is definitely
probably a um
a good tool to be have just because a
lot of the data we have is unstructured
and being able to pull from that
but
also understanding
you know
various uh classification models how
you're grouping you know individuals
and understanding various metrics within
the human resource area those are things
and i mentioned some of those already
again time to hire attrition you know
how the average number of people we we
have and how often they've left so so
it's really just a good way of digging
into
[Music]
demographic type of information and
trying to uncover you know
areas around different concepts
within
human capital and again and those fall
down to recruitment
talent acquisition learning the
development attrition
oh i think those are probably the four
biggest areas that you can look at
within people analytic or within human
capital that people analytics would
serve
thank you so much that's really helpful
i i see somebody asked on slido how much
of the people analytics team is focused
on data science and predictive modeling
versus reports and business intelligence
you mean hey well how much should well
it should be a combination of both of
those but within my team
right now
we do a little bit of everybody does a
little bit of everything unfortunately
we just don't have enough people to do
those things and a lot of that really
falls down to
our data pipeline and how we're able to
access our data
for the most part when i got here they
were primarily focused on
reporting
creating some type of visualization
creating some kind of
custom report or something like that
over the last couple of years i've been
trying to break that to where we've got
folks that focus on those types of
reports
in general
and then breaking off a group that's
looking more at the data analytics the
modeling creating the the various
algorithms that we can utilize for
extracting skills and competencies or
taking a look again at our time to hire
models or our attrition models to
identify developing some simulations
so right now i'm trying to get it about
50 50.
but for the most part
everybody's doing a little bit of
everything even sometimes i have to go
in there and start looking at some
visualizations and create some quick
quick dashboards because it's coming
from high ups that we need this now
so
if i had the money
you know it would it would be an equal
team of both side of both capabilities
i would probably say about 20 people i
would need to to fulfill everything
we're trying to do
and all of those having the cons some of
those i would probably break it down to
about
i think i could get away with five or
six visualizers 10
data scientist and then the rest of
those being some type of data engineer
data architects
cool thanks for breaking it down like
that too like the a recipe
for the team i see um there's so many
great questions coming in right now and
and one that was asked a bit earlier was
in your opinion why should an average
person care about space exploration
well
it's not so much it's the space
exploration well it depends if your
curiosity and what's out there
interesting and that that's the biggest
thing uh just from knowing you know
what's going on in the space and knowing
your environment
but it's the tangential things that come
from space exploration because as we try
to learn how to get to space how to get
to lower low earth orbit in high earth
orbit and beyond into outer space
we we pick things up we we have to
figure things out about how do we handle
radiation how do we handle the lift uh
you know what type of software is
necessary to handle all of these things
what type of uh
communications are necessary
all of those things provide as we learn
in those things provide benefit to
humankind um
one of nasa's primary missions is to
benefit humankind if you look at our
mission that's one of the statements
down there is that we're not just doing
this for ourselves if
we're trying to make things better
across the world and it's not just about
going to space it's looking at the
different things that we do so
if you're not aware the international
space station is actually considered a
national lab
we do experiments out there we conduct
thousands of experiments over the last
decade all of those experiments a lot of
them are medical a lot of them are high
radiation but there's a lot of other
things that go out there
all of those have generated some type of
patent potentially products that benefit
back to uh the economy as well as
humankind um
so they all you know
and you see you've seen the commercial
velcro you know
memory foam all of those things that
some of the things that are out there
right now we're all created because nasa
was looking at ways of doing things but
we make
we have a software transition um site to
where you can see what kind of software
we've open source out there and you can
utilize that software for free
for i think trying to remember for like
three years
and then you've got to make some kind of
decision how you want to commercialize
that we all are
we've got a lot of different technology
transfer groups where a lot of our
technology that's being created we
eventually try to get that out into the
public
we want
the economy to utilize our things that
are being created and there's several
companies that have been created based
on
technology that started at nasa gone out
into into the public and it has provided
you know thousands of jobs and more
money back into the economy
that's fascinating thanks david i just
put a link into the chat i'm pretty sure
that is
the link you're referencing is it just
code.nasa.gov
that's one of them but no let me i'll
look for him while we're talking okay or
you can share it later too i try to get
i try and guess at some of the links as
we go
um
i see sam just asked the question um you
put the little star so i'll read it
is people analytics at nasa using our or
our studio products and if so what
impact has this had
so
yes the simple answer is yes we are
using um
our studio
ecosystem we've got the r studio connect
the workbench and
uh we're licensed for that
and
it's having a lot of impact uh as far at
least in my opinion anyway first how our
capabilities of what we're trying to do
when i
joined the people analytics team you
know again a couple of years ago it was
primarily a
the team primarily walked around with
our laptops i hate to say this with
their laptops with tableau on it and
said okay here's what i did here's the
visualization and i'll share it with you
so the cot you know i had to work on
making these things readily available or
easily accessible not only to our to the
team but to the end users and so
our studio was one of those ways of
doing that to be able to create
visualizations and
reports and presentations and everything
else you can do within the our ecosystem
and make that easily accessible to not
only the the data scientists and the
team but to the end users to see those
visualization
but at the same time we were working
across nasa to create what we call the
enterprise data platform
which was trying to develop that that
pipeline of those workflows to to make
it easy to trans transmit that data from
our authoritative source to a
presentation layer the ocio team was
working on developing a tableau server
instance with
an alteryx no code low code
capability and then connecting that to
uh
to the authoritative data source that
was their start
of a
enterprise data platform
now
it's it re that's okay in my mind for
for those that are more of a data
analyst
in in those that that are more focused
on creating visualizations and creating
using data has already been curated
to to create those reports of
visualizations
from a data scientist or data engineer
who's actually trying to use data that's
dirty you know and try to clean it up
and make it more tidy
we needed other tools to do that and
that's where you know utilizing our
studio and and one of the reasons i
chose with when with our studio is
because of their continuous
growth in how they're using multiple
language especially python in our
combination of those two because half my
team was python and half my team was r i
needed to figure out a way that they
could both utilize those things so we
kind of use the combination of our r
studio and also vs code
you know for some things but
we're able to still create good
applications both in r and python and
put those on the connect server
which has provided a lot of value
internally within our organization and
starting to show
some value externally as they're seeing
what we're developing and how we're
migrating to that
i wish it would be a little further
along we is again i don't have enough
people enough staff to to
get these things to the level i would
like um such much that that i'm probably
the well i'm i'm the admin for the r
servers right now uh only because i'm
the one that has the most experience on
on administrating those
and i need to get the ocio group to
understand okay now you guys have to
take this over and get people trained up
on it
so probably a lot more information than
you wanted
that's great david thank you
it's cool to you to hear the teams using
both our studio and vs code too in both
the python and our users
i see i'm laughing at your comment or
question libya where you said does nasa
use shiny i may die of excitement
we do use shiny uh and it's actually one
of the things that it's uh um
it's well thought it's sought out for by
now some of our end users but definitely
our my team has really come to you
utilize it quite extensively
in developing some of our products
so it's doing very well
i'm trying to to get this
need to upskill and still a little bit
more
utilizing some of the more modular
capabilities and i just saw that with
epsilon released the rhino
uh system um i need to take a little bit
more in-depth look at that uh to see how
we can we can make the the application
so
for lack of a better word more more uh
internet type ready looking at we are
more robust looking
we we started with shiny as more of a
dash using the shiny dashboards
and then built went from there to more
shiny applications in developing that
most of my folks are are developers so
we don't have a whole lot of the
web developers with javascript or html
which can really enhance some of those
shiny apps so we're trying to pick some
of that up so that we can make those
applications a little bit more robust
that's great thanks for all the great
questions here too
um
maybe shifting gears a little bit
somebody asked what's important when it
comes to leadership and people
management and such a technical company
with number driven projects
listening and communication i you know
it's probably from a leadership
standpoint
uh really understanding the needs not
only of your your end users your
customers for you know or
who you're delivering your products to
but also understanding the needs
um and
constraints that your team may be having
all right it's one thing just to you
know say go out and do this um but you
really have to be there for them to to
break some of the the roadblocks they
may be having but also just provide a
landing ear sometimes i've got a lot of
you know early career
uh people that have come in here um and
and you need to you kind of be you need
to be their mentor you need to be
sometimes just a coach or a friend
or just a listening ear just to get that
understanding i had a conversation with
with one of my team members this morning
um
just going as a code review he was happy
to see and
rachel may get back with you on this
we're having an issue with a dash app on
the connect server that it works well on
the desktop
but it
when we post it on the connect server
the callbacks
run very very slow
so we were just doing some code review
and he just really appreciated the time
with just me sitting down within the
looking over things probably for looking
at suggestions so as a leader you need
to be able to do that but you also need
to be able to be you know have some good
constructive criticism on things they
need to improve upon or things they need
to to work on
or just learn about
but those are letting them know that
that's
common for anybody in this industry
again the guy that i was talking to this
morning because i'm embarrassed by my
code and i said no don't be embarrassed
this is how we learn is how we go
and i think it was
hadley that i heard from hadley but it
was 10 years ago you go through a
million lines of code just to get one
one good million lines of bad code to
get to one line of good code or
something like that
so it takes a lot of practice to go
through your code to get to that
level that your your code is easier to
read or easier to go work with and
things like that so never be embarrassed
with your code just get it out there and
work with it
those are great tips thank you
um steve i see you put a question into
the zoom chat do you want to jump in
and then robert i see you have your hand
raised too so i'm calling you after
all right hi david i'm a fellow
administrator of our studio service
and we're looking to
transition over to a better architected
way we do our studio so i was interested
whether or not you uh
run your own in-house r studio servers
or use running externally
uh
and what you think you're talking about
transferring this to a sort of mainline
support department
what things do you think your what
response
in terms of feeling comfortable about
handing over your responsibilities to
them
what do you need from back from them do
you need like slas or
or some sort of uh
comfort
comfort factor that they will look after
your look after your
baby so uh
again let's start with the first
question i think do we it's all on
premise we do everything on premise for
the most part unless well
i i'll go back a little bit it's a
combination combination it's in-house
it's on premise in a gov cloud
if that makes any sense you know it's a
government uh
secured um
cloud resources so i have uh in one
instance uh i've got a a contractor in
california that handles some of the
servers there i also have a gcp gov
cloud instance where i have my
development servers
there um
so so we've got them in various
locations
so
and and that would be the always with
within that for the most part it's going
to have to be either on-premise or some
kind of secure class i'm sorry these are
physical servers or we're talking about
uh government's version of aws sort of
government version of aws some kind of
cloud so they're they're vms you know
gcp uh compute engines or ec2s on aws
um and that's kind of where we're going
towards for the most part we're trying
to go more cloud-centric
to utilize those type of resources
but definitely there has to be some type
of concept of operations in some type of
sla as we move them over to get an
understanding of
it takes more to manage a a system such
as an r ecosystem and this could be for
anything but in this particular case
than just keeping the operating system
up to date
you know you you've got to do more than
that and that's kind of what they're
focused on right now and one of the
reasons i took over the administration
because they weren't looking at how do
we update the rstudio connect server or
the or the workbench server in a timely
manner how do we make sure that we have
the right packages
necessary within the operating system um
it's you can do a quick instance of an
ec2
but there's a lot of dependencies that
uh
the r servers require they have to also
be installed
um they didn't understand that so i had
to walk them through a lot of those
things with those dependencies that need
to be done and normal dependencies that
a lot of other applications have it
that's nothing you know out of the
ordinary um but making sure that it
worked properly and then how to make
those connections and then setting up
the
different
things that need to be thought about and
work through um and those and those
should be some kind of concept of
operations who's going to manage those
in some stuff sla that it's going to be
done in a timely manner and things like
that
are you using any infrastructures codes
or is it all handcrafted at the moment
in our individual applications
you know in the in terms of the
infrastructure the asteroid servers and
the like yeah it's all out of the box
right now if that's what you mean
okay
so you imagine so
when you build your systems you manually
add the libraries whatever it's not all
generated automatically by file code
no yeah well we got package manager yeah
well yeah actually yeah so for for the
for the our live packages and things
like that but when we're building the
the actual
vms for storing for the actual servers
themselves we have created a workflow
for how to create what needs to be added
to that so that if we need to replicate
that we we've got that done
uh and it has to have an image of a
clean instance
sorry i'm ready to go if we have if we
need something
okay
steve you're reminding me i know we
talked about at some point having a an
administrators meet up too we definitely
have to go back to that as well
um
robert i see you have your hand raised
you want to jump in
yeah i just wanted to sort of ask um
i'm sort of in the same position where
i'm leading a team but then i'm also
like the administrator of like workbench
and connect and product and you know
so
it's a
it's a tough balancing act so i'm
curious sort of if you have tips or
takeaways for how you balance you know
being a lot of meetings leading teams
trying to give direction big picture you
know thinking and then also trying to
figure out like
you know why is dev toolset 11 not
enabled in this like our profile for
this person
is on my team you know uh yeah that
that's a it's a tough act to balance um
i i you know i feel for you i understand
part of it i've finally started to learn
how to delegate a little bit
uh and making sure that you know
especially as i brought down new people
onto the team and some of the things
that i was working on i'm able to
delegate some of the work being done and
just perhaps provide oversight rather
than technical
work on that so unfortunately i've had
to back away from my
technical work that's you know
developing the nlp models or things like
that so that i can focus on some of the
stress you do have to give up a little
things here and there
the other thing is is i i have blocked
out time
on my calendar and said this is time you
know it's it's
you cannot go over this time nobody can
put anything on that time so that i can
focus on something that i need to focus
on whether it's thinking about strategy
or vision writing up documents or
working on the r servers um and i try to
do that
you know sometime you know at least an
hour a day for some things and then
every other friday i block out a big
chunk of times that this is the time i
need to work on things that um are i'm
having issues with but fortunately i've
been able to teach some of the
younger you know early career folks some
of these things and said okay now go
research this take a look at this and
let's figure out an answer and then
let's get back together see how we can
work we can work through that so
part of it is just you know breaking up
your day you know appropriately and then
learning how to delegate uh which i've
always had a hard time with i just had a
hard time saying no
yeah so you have to learn how to
delegate and get the experience
that's good advice thank you
and yeah
an admins chat would also i think be
helpful for some of us
that's great i'm seeing all the comments
in the chat about it too
um sloane i see you you had asked a
question in the chat too do you want to
jump in
sure um so when i think people analytics
one question that comes to mind is
understanding how
uh interview questions and the interview
process would potentially translate to
later job performance i'm just curious
if that's something that has been looked
into at nasa and like whether technical
interviews take-home projects or like
specific questions truly lead to a
better performance from a new employee
and if not nasa if the rest of the group
has any input um i'd be curious know
really anyone's working on that
so
to a degree i mean we started a project
to take a look at
it was more focused around
helping our raiders
identify executive level
individuals so so within the government
you you've got your your general
services group
which you know your gs 15 down down and
on down then you have your executive
level group which are those that are
appointed you know they apply for them
but they still have to be appointed
by the administration to that position
in order to get to that to to apply for
that you have to answer a huge level
well not a huge there's
a total of eight questions i think and
two technical qualifications
technical specific and technical general
questions
and raters look at those responses and
say okay this person fully qualified or
fully answered that question or this
person just missed the mark on that
question and some of them are more
technical some of them are also around
how you lead in some of your examples
there
so we've had an initiative underway to
take a look at past
responses
to see can we determine was this a good
response or a not so good response or
just a terrible response based on how
raiders have rated them in the past
it's tricky
because now we're taught where it's very
subjective in the sense we're trying to
evaluate how somebody wrote
what they wrote and then and what they
write actually
um answer that not only just answer the
question but provide
you know good substance to that to that
question uh and did it did it in a way
that would that made sense and provided
value not you know in other words like
me i'm not rambling not a whole lot of
rambling but but was very concise and
very accurate in what they were trying
to do it's uh
it was difficult because we came across
a lot of issues with the raiders first
of all that the raiders didn't all rate
the same
and they weren't trained how to rate or
what to look for it was just their
subjective based on their experience
so it was hard to identify how somebody
may have rated somebody really good but
they were another greater rated them not
so good or just average so there was a
lot of discrepancies there and then you
had to think about the ethical and legal
ramifications on that can we justify
the algorithm's response
legally to to the results that came out
and those are things that we had so
there's a lot of nuances a lot of things
you have to consider
but it's something we are looking at and
trying to figure out if there's a way of
doing it
and actually i think i saw kaggle
content or event
just recently about evaluating essays
but primarily it was they were looking
at that sixth sixth to twelfth grade um
essays but the concept very similar to
that to evaluating how they wrote it and
the value of of not not just the quality
of the writing but the
the content that was in there was it a
good content
thanks david
i realize there are a lot of other
anonymous questions that came in too so
i want to get to some of those
one was do you have opinions on
open source was it scary for people at
nasa to introduce it
um
yes i have opinions on open source i am
a big open source fan
um i i tend to believe it and it's uh
um
for for more often than not it is
probably a lot better it was easier to
understand easier to work with um and of
course as a software developer myself
you know it's it's good to know the
being able to see the back in a lot of
times which you can't see on some of the
types of products
was it scary i think in some cases it is
for some groups it was scary for i.t
security it was scary
because it's open source and they don't
and you've got to really take a look at
it don't know what's inside of it it
hasn't been vetted it hasn't gone
through a lot of different uh um
security
clearances or or checks or or things
like that so so it was scary for them
until until it became more
ubiquitous across the industry as being
utilized this is this was many years ago
when open source was just coming out
the other scary part is
is
maintenance and operations of the open
source software
you have many open source companies of
course you know have their their
commercial side where you can use them
for operation but a lot of organizations
use open source because it's less costly
to buy the software
but it's still there's still a cost to
maintain it and operate it and manage it
and people didn't understand that
and people then were realizing this
because in some cases it was costing
them more to use the open source
software than a commercial product
because they didn't have the staff
to manage that open source software
and maintain it um
and unfortunately kind of like i'm doing
with our studio right now
even though it's a commercial product
i started it as an open source i learned
how to manage it and maintain it but we
don't have a whole lot of other people
that know how to manage it and maintain
it so we have got to train those folks
up which is an additional cost um
but as we as we get more to the point
that we're using it as a more enterprise
type capability that cost will go down
because more and more people are
utilizing and going there
did i answer the entire question
i don't know who asked it but i think
that i answered
answered it if anybody wants more
contacts or follow up feel free to use
the the chat too
thank you david
jose i think i saw your hand was raised
at some point yes okay yes i i just was
a little curious about the data
retention policies at
nasa
and i also wanted to ask do you have to
get the poly to work there or
how does it work
when you're selected as a candidate
okay um
data retention okay well there's data
retention then there's records
management or records retention a couple
of different things you know there is a
government standard for records
retention on how long we have to keep
record a record
now record could be different than a
data than a data site so so data
retention on the other side that could
be
that's more dependent on the data owners
in in their organization and how long
they want to retain that data and what
is being used for so there's different
data governance policies uh depending on
the organization by organizations and
nasa i'm talking about
we're broken down of course into centers
and then across the center
you have different organizations inside
the centers from their hr their
procurement to their engineering
department to their medical department
things like that then across nasa you
also have programs uh ssnb the space
mission directorate and the armd
so they're there's a lot of different
ways nasa broken down so each of them
may have their own data governance and
data retention policies
so to get a job within nasa as a civil
servant
one of the first criteria is you have to
be a us citizen
yeah then once you get through the
process your if your resume makes it
through that
they do use some kind of certification
algorithm to say okay did this resume
meet what was asked for in the job
announcement did you capture all of the
different concepts that we were looking
for so we've got a list of requirements
there that
your does your resume show that you have
that requirement and if so then you get
what's called certified that means your
your resume clears that then it goes to
the hiring official to decide okay now
i've got all these resumes i've got to
read all these resumes to see which ones
i want to pull out which and we are
looking at ways of using some type of
methodologies or algorithms to kind of
fine-tune that a little bit and then
pull out ones that that the iron
official may think are better
for their for their current announcement
and that's something we're still working
on then you go through the interview
process
and the interview process um depending
again on the organization can be
different it could be a series of
questions and it's usually a panel
interview
uh you may have anywhere from three to
four people on the panel that ask you
questions and then afterwards they get
together and rate those questions and
then depending on they either bring you
back for second interviews um and then
will or look down to then finally make a
selection
but a polygraph um i think that's what
the question was um yes polygraph is not
not
i have not seen a polygraph but you do
get a background check
and those background checks are uh
lengthy can be lengthy i got two new
hires that there are a few things that i
can't give them access to because their
securities level their clearance level
hasn't reached to the level that i need
them to because their background check
hasn't completed yet
one more thing when there's pictures
taken say by the rovers out there in
mars stuff like that
do you get to uh capture the geolocation
on each picture and use that in your
data sets or
is is that depending on
um the technology that was available at
that time or
do you get do you get to see any of this
information or process it
in real time
good question
not my area of expertise as far as the
data set
um
itself
mean i can get access to the to the
images that come out and everybody
should have access through nasa images
i think it's one of the links there um
but
i'm going to say yes you know at least
on the latest i think we have a uh some
kind of core
well let me let me think through that
because yeah i'm sure they've got some
way of mapping it out and locations on
there
and they should have that capability
available there and the data should the
metadata should be stored in the
metadata somewhere
thank you
david
um i see someone had asked earlier
how does nasa tackle an aging workforce
a lot of fundamental knowledge may be
lost if a new cohort can't be trained
before existing staff retire
um another excellent question because we
do i mean i was just playing around with
some data earlier and looking at the
average age of our individuals and
you know we're up there in in the 50 60
areas is a good you know if you look at
the the distribution uh we've got a lot
of most of our folks are in the 50 60
age group and pretty close to retirement
so one of the things we did
2009 if i remember correctly
nasa implemented they would they already
had announced knowledge management
offices across each of the centers but
they implemented an online chief
knowledge officer across the agency uh
and in the primary one of the primary
you know
objectives of that
office there
was to help capture information across
the agency so each of the centers do
things maybe a little differently while
i was at jsc they would anybody that was
getting to retire that was what they
would consider a high level target as
far as knowledge they would interview
them and and to basically write a book
on everything that they knew and try to
capture that
there's also other management techniques
that we knowledge management techniques
we use lessons learned trying to capture
that across the various organizations
case studies
looking at different issues or things
that may have happened in developing
case studies on that
we've also started to implement
many different groups to again
sometimes we can be kind of a wild wild
west where each organization is doing
some of their own things but a couple of
groups of instituted some very good
wikis
uh to where people are capturing this
data just for that example they've
realized that you know we have an aging
workforce and we need to capture this
information so those things are going to
there so there's a lot of things going
on to try to capture from a knowledge
management perspective uh this type of
data and making it available and
searchable
for you know
people that are coming in and now and in
the future
thanks david
okay i know an hour is going by very
quickly and there are a lot of questions
still here so i'm gonna try and go
through a few more
one was how do you all think about
system assessment
any follow-up comparing a higher's
actual performance to the
prediction
and then also how do you think about
equity and diversity that's a lot of
questions maybe into one
so um
we're not yet into the complete
predictive capabilities within people
analytics
one of the things i had to do early on
to management is to is to first get them
to understand the difference between
descriptive and predictive
and trying to understand you know why we
needed to
upscale or improve our infrastructure
uh especially as the amount of data they
were they were somewhat happy with we've
got all this data here and we're able to
use it well
kind of you're able to use it you're
able to i'm able to tell you right now
what's good today based on this data set
but i can't look in the past and i can't
use that data to tell you what we might
be able to see in the future
and that's where we need to get to more
of a predictive model
so
i guess the answer the first question is
no we can't do that right now but it's
definitely something that it's on my
roadmap to try to be able to look at
those type of things to understand you
know did we hire the people we hire
actually pan out i guess for lack of a
better phrase
and how do you define the diversity
equity
inclusion so there's a lot of things out
there um
this book i can get to and i don't know
if you can see
this is a decent book for deia inclusive
inclusionalytics the new terminology
they put out there
it's a good book just to understand deia
or diversity equity inclusion and
accessibility different concepts around
it
this book just came out a couple of
months ago but
it's all of you it depends on
well diversity is fairly easy enough i
think to to understand you know do you
it's your population that you're working
with
diverse enough the key there is diverse
compared to
what you know is it good just is it just
supposed to be 50 50 all the way across
or or what are we looking at so do we
compare it against the population across
the united states
across the whole world across the area
you know that we're we're looking at you
know if i'm at johnson space center in
houston am i only considered concerned
about the population around that area
or or
you know so those are a lot of questions
that have to be answered around there
equitable
and inclusive inclusion more about
whether the individual feels like they
belong and they're being heard
within that organization
thank you and thank you for the book
recommendation too i just put that into
the chat as well
um trevor i see you just asked a
question you said it's a left field
question but i feel like it's on track
too do you want to ask it live
sorry
good day i was just trying to find the
unknown button
you know um it is some i'm just reading
an article recently
and it spoke about
um
writing your resumes for
an algorithm or ai system as opposed to
a resume that would be evaluated by
humans
so i'm really really interested in
finding out um any anybody your thoughts
uh on on that whole situation in terms
of tweaking your resume is to be
evaluated by
an ai system as opposed to a human being
i don't know if david want to take the
first goal
you know it's interesting because i i
know that
um
a lot of people have written
well at least this is the intern to do
that certification process that i talked
about earlier where you capture you make
sure that your resume
catches all of the different objectives
or requirements within the announcement
that's kind of writing towards an
algorithm because you want to capture it
because there is a kind of a tool they
utilize to make sure that they find
those things in there so a lot of times
you got to make it's just basically a
keyword based capability that that
keyword show up in both areas uh so
that's kind of right into it but
in the end
yeah it's still a human that's got to
read through it
and you really need to be able to write
to the job and to in in the humans going
to look at it
decide and try to get
feel that you really want this decision
or this is somebody that really would
would be a good fit
and you can't do that with an algorithm
at least not yet i don't think you can
yeah and and you're going to need to
understand what that person's trying to
get across
but a lot of it comes also back down to
to the to the interview process itself
um
so i don't know i mean i'm torn a little
bit of both i mean i think i think
there's benefits in using the algorithms
to help
narrow this election down but it's still
going to come down to a human making the
final decision
i'll
say if anybody else wants to jump in and
and add
context or if you want to add to that
discussion point feel free but i also
want to say david if you have to run to
another meeting
just let us know we can all hang out
here still
actually i do have a one o'clock
okay
but i'll take i'll take one more
question if anybody has a burning
question they have they want to ask
yes do you guys use analytics
to determine which company
um
gets a contract like spacex versus
amazon and stuff like that or is there
some sort of ai that's
that gives you indicators to go
with this sort of technology instead of
another
type of technology
uh not yet uh and primarily because
those are protestable
issues so when you do a contract within
the us government and in a company you
know
many companies apply for that contract
um
and their selection is made there are
many ways the the people who didn't lose
who didn't get the contract can protest
that and and that gives an easy
area right now to say i'm going to
protest that ai that that was utilized
and that would slow things down a lot so
until legal has basically said that's
not something we should we should or
could be doing right now
but that being said that doesn't mean
we're not looking at it not to make the
decision but to as an indicator to weigh
it right that's what i meant
yeah no there's there's there's no
um
ai right now that's doing something like
that or ml let's do it that's doing that
right now
there's probably depending on the on the
contractors who they've got some
spreadsheets out there where they're
just tallying up you know individual
again raiders
scoring on that company right and come
up with a weighted score
but nothing that's being done
programmatically just because of those
legal concerns at least that's what i've
been told in the past when i when i
brought it up um but we are from a from
a human capitalist perspective trying to
work with the procurement to try to work
on some of these things to see how
maybe not so much in the contract itself
but on the performance of the current
contractor based on their workforce and
and what their what they're doing right
now within a procurement standpoint
thank you
thank you so much david i know you have
to run to another meeting but really
appreciate you jumping on here and
sharing your experience and insights
thank you all i appreciate it it's been
fun
if you're happy to re connect on
linkedin if anybody wants to
just feel free out and if you got any
further questions let me know or get
into rachel we'll be happy to try to
answer them
perfect thank you so much everybody
all right bye-bye thank you all for the
great questions too i'll share david's
linkedin
here in just a moment in the chat but if
there were other questions that we could
kind of all
chat about with each other if there's
any
you